reg what did you see last night what did
you expect last night well two things
that stand out to me number one turnover
especially for the Cavaliers I believe
they had 20 or 21 we already know how
high octane the Golden State Warriors
offenses they're the best scoring team
in basketball you give them extra
possessions and you know you mentioned
Kevin Durant that's a recipe for
disaster and mind you they did all of
this with probably the third best scorer
who has struggled throughout this
postseason klay Thompson shooting 3 of
16 you cannot turn the basketball over
give them extra possession see out shot
and think you're going to win number 2
easy point it was like a layup drill
especially for Kevin Durant in that
first half dunk after dunk if you're
going to give number one if you're going
to give them extra possessions turnovers
and you're going to give them points in
the paint which they dominated there's
no way you can beat the Golden State
Warriors it's I don't know what the
answer is if you're coach ty lue but
number one defensively to me you've got
to pick up full and you've got to keep
them out of the paint and that's easier
said than done because when you watch
the Warriors play everyone's always
running to the three-point line because
they're such great 3-point shooters well
that opens it up for draymond Green
Kevin Durant who number one now we have
38 points but the assists because he's
such a great driver those two things
stood out to me the most in Game one all
right what are the changes that
Cleveland has well look to meet LeBron
played great in that first half along
with Kyrie you've got to get better
offensive contributions but to me it's
all going to start with better effort at
the defensive end and to meet that lies
on Kevin Love
you can't let Pachulia get offensive
rebounds and Shumpert and jr. Smith have
to do a better job at limiting KD and
excuse me Katie and Steph Curry
but once again
klay Thompson who has not played well
this postseason at some point in time is
going to find his stroke it's safe to
say that he was three of sixteen last
night and had wide open looks so to me
you've got to have better effort there's
not a lot of X's and O's it all comes
down to heart and effort what do you do
with klay Thompson what would you say to
him just play your game shooter shoot I
mean I'm surprised that this if you want
to call it a slump has gone on this long
what I've loved about him it hasn't
affected him at the other end yeah
because he's doing a great job
defensively and he's one of the better
two-way players in the game but shooters
shoot and that's my whole point is at
some point in time he's going to have
one of those games like when he had 61
on 11 dribbles not that he'll have 61 in
the finals but he's gonna have one of
those breakout games where everything's
going to seem to be going and that's
their third best scorer on this team so
I mean it's a challenge for the
Cavaliers you know before the series I
had the Cavs
winning this in six you don't have to
start yet I just thought what I saw when
we covered them in the Eastern
Conference Finals to me they still have
the best player on the floor and LeBron
James now it didn't really kind of
manifest itself in Game one because that
was Kevin Durant but they still have the
best player and they have the best in
the paint closer and Kyrie Irving but
they're going to have to get more
contributions from Kevin Love and jr.
Smith and other guys to chip in Durant
said it was going to be a basketball
decision as to why he was if he was
leaving and where he was going does this
validate the basketball decision part of
this that he was going to a system that
catered to him where you can't cover him
you know you can't double-team him that
there's ball movement he gets open looks
he can beat you inside outside in 10 15
20 25 years will we look back and say
you know he left OKC to go to Golden
State Warriors and win three four or
five championships because
the way they are built now Bob Myers and
Steve curb Mike Brown and that brain
trust and the Warriors I mean they're
built to go to the finals easily what's
the next five to seven years so when we
look back in 10 15 20 years we're not
going to talk about him defecting and
going there we're going to talk about
his championships and bottom line at the
end of the day that's all the media and
the fans that's what they talk about
well did he want a championship at the
end of the day Kevin Durant is going to
win multiple championships and that's
basically all what we should be focusing
on personally I'm disappointed because
it's a small market that took a hit but
all fans talked about all media talk
about is Championships okay so he's
going to win his championship so I pat
him on the back for that personally I
don't like it but it's about
championship if you could change your
prediction would you change it I hate
doing that I'm going to ride it out and
you should it's only white LP it's only
one game right I've seen James there's a
both meaningless game not meaningless
game because it's always important to
win your games but it's only game one if
you ask me this after Game three or four
that's a different story but there's
plenty of time remember they lost by 15
last year 33 in Game two and still won
the series right so there's still you
know room for the Cavaliers to get going
but they've got to play better and have
better effort they have to have multiple
closeout in play you have to make
multiple efforts defensively if you're
ever going to have a chance to be Golden
State you you almost have to be perfect
and there has to be perfect for six to
seven games
Reggie Miller joining us NBA on TNT
hall-of-famer I had a couple of quick
questions here you can have Kyrie or you
can have Steph Curry if I'm an owner
you're starting your team right now at
their ages so you got you got Kyrie and
you got strike
you got you got them for the next five
years you can have Kyrie or Steph Curry
who you go that is so difficult because
you cannot go wrong with either or but
if I'm an owner and I'm thinking about
marketing and all that probably Steph
because I'm looking at the big picture
I'm looking at dollars if I'm a general
manager president closing the game on
goal with Kyrie because he's a closer
he's a bonafide closer does that kind of
answer I know I'm hedging but Kyrie is a
man that dude is a killer but if you're
talking about marketing I mean the guy's
a two-time MVP Kyrene oh no Tom I'm
serious
Kyrie the killer man I'm going to take
Kyrie even though I think step is a
better player right now but I would take
Kyrie because he's 25 and he's grown up
since LeBron got there but I would take
Kyrie because he's 25 and Steph is what
29 and if I'm going to have him for the
next five years I want 25 to 30 not as
109 to 34 so I don't know have a tear
enough the one the one in done rule the
commissioner opened it up he was on Fox
Sports Radio and he talked about you
know can we do something here do we make
it two years in college do we let him
come out of high school if I put if I
put this to a vote of players in the NBA
right now what is the ideal situation
for the one-and-done
what do you think that they would come
up with well number one let me ask the
question when can a young man or woman
sign up to join the Armed Forces at 18
18 if you're old enough to do that you
should be old enough to go into the NBA
and I'm fine with that
I am fine right now I am fine with that
too here's a couple things all right I
just don't understand why they cannot
adopt what Major League Baseball does
with their their system if you think
you're bold enough and your parents
think you're good enough and you person
think you're good enough to go pro and
you sign out of high school then so be
it you'll be in the farm system whatever
you'll make it to the major leagues but
if you don't and you go to college they
have you for what like three years right
in the NFL yes it No
in the NFL correct but they'll be other
in baseball two base knives for three
years - yes yes in baseball - why can't
we adopt that which the NFL in Major
League Baseball does what and if you
know you go to whatever college and you
ball out and you think you can leave you
get penalized like you can't be drafted
for another two more years so that makes
it five years well I don't understand
why the NBA cannot adopt that rule
I'm all for kids coming out at 18 if
they think they're good enough and they
want to risk and gamble it great but if
they don't think they can make it and
they need some seasoning at the
collegiate level if you sign to go to
Georgetown UCLA Dayton Columbia Harvard
whatever and you think you got it you're
got to be there for three years I don't
understand why the NBA can't do that
I would like for I would like for
everybody to look at the NBA the way
look at the other sports it's it's we
allow this to happen in tennis or golf
and hockey and baseball if you're not
good enough and you're going to take the
chance
fine oh I I'm amazed at how much we
invest in these 18 year olds that you
know we're trying to protect them from
what's going to happen if they don't
make it in the NBA we don't care about
that we want to protect the NBA and we
want to protect college basketball so
this is selfish on the fans part not
thinking about what the kid what's best
for the kid or the fact that that's what
they want to major in that's what their
future is if it doesn't work out so what
you know that happens to everybody in
all walks of life and the key word
you're just saying there is it gamble
and take a chance if you're 18 years old
and you want to take that chance yeah
you should have every single right to be
able to say you know what I want I want
to test it at the highest level but if
you're on the fringe and you kind of
know that you're not going to be a lot
of rebound player or a first rounder and
you need that seasoning of the
collegiate level and you end up wanting
to go to you know
USC or Pepperdine you've got to be there
for two or three years yeah I like to
hear I like two years because it forces
you to go to college it forces you to be
doing something that hey you might even
enjoy this and it doesn't make uh you
know professors and you know presidents
look foolish when it comes to college
and actually what college is supposed to
be and really right now these kids but
they go for what four months yeah five
months six months you know come on I
mean it's like a joke
he's Reggie Aloysius Miller the Hall of
Famer reg Thank You Theodore you're
always the best I love my dance they're
always spitting fire really yes they are
and by the way yeah I'm with you I would
not even pick up a doughnut are you
kidding me that stage right at the
bottom of your guts you using point it
I'm disappointed in my Danette because
looking at a few of them they need to be
on a treadmill instead of eating
doughnuts what are you a bad food
because you're in in Carmel shape hot
fudge sundaes oh they drive me crazy
chocolate anything chocolate is my
Achilles heel seriously ah but give me a
brownie sundae it's hard for me to turn
it down
it is brownie sundaes drives me crazy
yes Polly Michael Jordan let himself go
a little bit working out for him I'm
we're following that train like Reggie's
two in shape you can't be you can never
be too in shape yeah you don't need what
you love sometimes doughnuts they sit at
the bottom of your belly it's hard to
get out eventually I'll come out
finished with Rene's later alrighty
Thank You reg appreciated and Reggie
Aloysius Miller junior the third the Dan
Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience